[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون ساعه
الايقاع السريع والمختلف والمعلومات
المباشره الوافيه وفيها الكثير البدايه من
العناوين
بعد اوكرانيا
ساحه حرب جديده بين روسيا والغرب
خمسه عشر وزيرا جديدا لولايه اردوغان
الجديده بدان وشمشك الابرز
وايضا في ملفات الساعه 60
في ليبيا اتفاق على موعد الانتخابات لكن
بلا توقيع الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل
الملاحقات من كل حدب وصوب الملياردير
الامريكي محاصر بالتهم خصوصيه تويتر ودوت
كوين
[موسيقى]
كثيرون يعتبرون ما يحصل في اوكرانيا
امتدادا الانهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي الذي
ترك وراءه حدودا مشتعله واقليه روسيه في
دول حديثه نشات عن التفكك وبحجه الاضطهاد
الديني او اللغوي تتدخل اله موسكو
لحمايتها كان هذا الحل في جورجيا ثم في
اوكرانيا لكن غير بعيدا عن روسيا تعتبر
يوغوسلافيا قبل تفككها مثالا مصغرا اشترى
الاحداث الروسيه ولكن بصوره اكثر تعقيدا
[موسيقى]
ورغم النقاط المشتركه بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي ويوغوسلافيا الا ان تفكك الاخيره
كان اكثر تعقيدا صربيا عكس روسيا لم
تعتبرها الامم المتحده وريثه
تلو الاخرى حتى جاء دور كسوفه عام 2008
بلاد الدوله الحديثه كان عصيرا وفرض تدخل
النيتو لانهاء الحرب التي اتهمت فيها
بلغراد بالتطهير العرقي صربيا هذه المره
عكس الدول الخمس المستقله الاخرى لم تعترف
باستقلاليه تعتبرها امتدادها الحضري
والديني لكن الامر لا يقتصر على صربيا
وحدها كوسوفو بقيت تحت عهده الامم المتحده
وبحمايه قوات النيتو حتى عام 2012 وخلال
هذه الفتره حصدت كوسوفو اعتراف 99 دوله
اثنتا عشره منها اوروبيه
الاعترافات لكوسوفو لم تكن من اجل نيل
عضويه الامم المتحده بسبب اعتراض روسيا
والصين دعم طبيعي لحليف النادر في اوروبا
لكن الحجه هي اضطهاد الاقليه الصربيه في
كوسوفو هذا السبب هو اهم اسباب استقلال
كسوف عن صربيا لكن الامر انقلب الان
وصربيا تتهم الالبان وهم غالبيه سكان
كوسوفو باقصاء الاقليه الصربيه
كوسوفو البلد الذي يسكنه مليونان و200 الف
نسمه اغلبهم من اصل البانيا
94% لكن السته في المئه المتبقيه يشكلها
الكوسوفيون من اصول صربيا 160 الفا في
المجموعه يسكنون في شمال البلاد ويشكلون
الاغلبيه هناك
لم تكن حكومه كوسوفو يوما مستعده لسماع
الناس او فهم رغباتهم يحتاج الناس في
برشتينا الى فهم ان جميع الصرب في شمال
كوسوفو يعتبرون صربيا بلدهم وليس كوسوفو
وهذا امر طبيعي لكن حكومه بريشتينا ترفض
الاعتراف بهذا الواقع
10 بلديات في المجموعه تقطنها اغلبيه
صربيه بقيه مصدر الصداع لكوسوفه الا ان
خريطه طريق اوروبيه جاءت عامه 2013 لحلا
واقعي اقنع جميع الاطراف الخطه كانت تهدف
لاعطاء البلديات التي تسكنها الاغلبيه
الصربيه حريه تشكيل كيان موحد يتمتع بحريه
اداره شؤونه الاداريه والثقافيه امر لم
يحصل طبعا ممثل الاقليه الصربيه استنكروا
تجاهل الحكومه للاتفاق وكحل اخير لجا
المنتخبون في البلديات الصربيه نهايه
العام الماضي الى الاستقاله من اجل خلق
فراغ دستوري كانت هذه خطوه اولى ثم جاءت
دور اعلى السكان الذين قاطعوا الانتخابات
نسبه المشاركه لم تتعدى 3% ورغم ذلك
اعتبرت الحكومه ان الانتخابات شرعيه وعينت
رؤساء بلديات البانيين في بلداتنا الصربيه
وهنا خرجت الامور عن السيطره ومن حدود
كوسوفو ايضا
[موسيقى]
ازمته كسوفه والاقليات الصربيه فيها لم
تحل منذ سنوات والسبب ليس مقتصرا على
تعقيد الازمه بل لانها تختصر الصراع
العالمي بين الشرق والغرب روسيا تربطها
علاقات تاريخيه بالصربيا ورفضت بشده قصف
الناتو الذي انهى سياده صربيا على كوسوفو
وهي الان تدعم كل الاقليات الصربيه في
البوسنه وكوسوفو بشكل مباشر
هناك انفجار كبير في وسط اوروبا في نفس
المكان الذي شن فيه النيتو عام
1999 عدوانا على يوزلافيا منتهكا جميع
مبادئ اتفاقيه السينكي وغيرها من وثائق
منظمه الامن والتعاون في اوروبا الوضع
مقلق لكن الغرب يستعمل نفس الاساليب مع كل
من يرغب في انشاء سياسه مستقله
البعض دعم موسكو للاقليات الصربيه في
البلقان الى اسباب دينيه وثقافيه لكن
الحرب في اوكرانيا جعلت صربيا تبتعد عن
حلمها في الانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي حسب
بروكسل والسبب رفضها المشاركه في العقوبات
الغربيه المفروض على روسيا دعموا صربيا
لروسيا رافقه دعم شعبي من كل صرب البلقان
للعمليات العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
لكن هناك اسباب اخرى اكثر
[موسيقى]
في شؤون دول البلقان اهلا بك تعزيزات
الصربيه على الحدود وايضا النيتو يعزز
قوات كوماندو تركيا ومحاولات بالمقابل
للتهدئه ما هي الان احتمالات اشتعال
الصراع
يا سمساوي
منذ راينا هذه الاحتجاجات العنيفه
وحاله الفوضى حيث حيث قام الاقليه من
الصرب بمهاجمه القوات المسؤوله عن للحفاظ
عن السلم والامان فراينا
رايت راينا في نفس الوقت
مظاهرات سلميه لكن الوضع خطر ويمكننا
القول
ان هذه الاقليات الصربيه في الشمال لا
تزال حتى الان يرغبون
باطلاق سراح هؤلاء الذين تم اعتقالهم
اثناء المظاهرات ولا يرغبون من العمد
البلديات تولي المناصب بعد ان تم انتخابهم
في شمال صربيا الوضع
ينم عن وجود مظاهرات سلميه لكنه في نفس
الوقت خطرا
الماضي حربا في التسعينيات لكن هل تحتمل
الاطراف الداعمه ان يشتعل الصراع الان
خاصه مع الحرب الاوكرانيه هل تحتمل صراعا
جديدا وجبهه جديده اضافيه
اعتقد ان ما يحدث هناك هو قد يكون ملائما
لروسيا ولا سيما بانها تشن حربها على
اوكرانيا هذا قد يسبب الصداع لحلف الناتو
لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وحاله من عدم
الاستقرار في جزء اخر من اوروبا فهذا اخر
شيء قد يرغب قد ترغب به دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي والنيتو بوجود هذه البقعه من
التوتر فقد يكون هناك احتمال لاندلاع
صراعا ويتطلب الامر وقتا كما راينا بان
الناتو ارسل 700 جندي اضافيه فهذا الامر
ملائم جدا لروسيا اللي زعزعه الاستقرار في
تلك البقعه الاوروبيه وراينا في وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه والصربيه بان الروس
ووسائلها الاعلاميه حول ما يحدث في في
كوسوفو ويلومون بذلك على الغ
يسعون الروس
لزياده التوتر من اجل ان نحو باللائمه على
الغرب او حول ما يحدث في شمال كوسوفو قد
تكون مساله ملائمه لروسيا لفتح هذه الجبهه
الاخرى وزعزعه الاستقرار في كوسوفو ولكن
في منطقه البلقان بصوره عامه نعم شكرا
جزيلا لكم
بصمه سريعه لوزير تركيا جديد في الساعه
بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد 15 وزيرا جديدا استهلا
بهم الرئيس التركي اردوغان تعديلاته
الحكوميه في فترته الرئاسيه الجديده خطوه
تظهر تغيرات كبيره في سياساته فتره مجدا
جديده للجمهوريه التركيه وعاد بها في خطاب
التنصيب هذه الفتره بدات باسماء بارزه
يراهن عليها اردوغان الاستعاده تفوقه
خارجيا وداخليا
تركيا
تم قبول مشروعنا الخاص باستكمال بناء
تركيا في القرن الجديد من قبل امتنا في
الرابع عشر من مايو
لقد اعطى شعبنا الاغلبيه في البرلمان اولا
للتحالف الشعب بثلاثمائه وثلاثه وعشرين
نائبا ثم اعطى الرئاسه لي باكثر من اثنتين
وخمسين بالمئه من الاصوات قائلا لندع
الاستقرار يستمر وندع تركيا تنمو لخمس
سنوات اخرى
تركيا
استبدلها اردوغان جميع اعضاء حكومته
باستثناء وزير الصحه فخر الدين قوجا ووزير
الثقافه والسياحه محمد نوري ارسوئي قطاعات
شهد التطورا ملحوظا خلال السنوات الاخيره
ستكون معالجه المشاكل الاقتصاديه على راسي
اولويات اردوغان حيث بلغت تضخم
43.7% بسبب السياسه غير التقليديه
المتمثله في خفض اسعار الفائده لتحفيز
النمو لذا جاء تعيين تعيين محمد الشمشك في
منصبي وزير الخزانه والماليه ليعكس نيه
اردوغان تغيير سياسته الاقتصاديه التي
كانت دائما معارضه لرفع قيمه الفائده
وزاره الخارجيه ذهبت اليهاكان فيدان رئيس
وكاله الاستخبارات التركيه منذ عام 2010
هو دبلوماسي الظل وكاتم اسرار اردوغان
بحسب وصف الاخير
جهدي من اجل وحده اراضي وان رفاهيه دولتنا
وامتنا ساستمر في العمل نحو رؤيه السياسه
الخارجيه الوطنيه القائمه على استقلال
دولتنا عن اي تاثير خارجي وسياده مطلقه
لامتنا
ما وزاره الداخليه فاستبدل القومي سليمان
سويلو بوالي اسطنبول علي ييرلكايا المطلع
على ملف مكافحه الارهاب منذ كان واليا في
ولايات الشرق حيث المواجهات مع مقاتلي حزب
العمال الكردستاني اما وزاره الدفاع
فاستمرت سياسه ما بعد محاوله الانقلاب في
2016 ان يكون الوزير من قاده الجيش فجاء
تعيين رئيس الاركان يشارك جولر خلفا
لهالوسي اكار
[موسيقى]
وصفه هو الرئيس التركي بانه صندوق اسراره
كان اول من علم باحتماليه حدوث انقلاب
2016 وزير الخارجيه كان افيدان ابرز وزراء
اردوغان الجدد صامت وغامض لا مقابلات
تلفزيونيه ولا مؤتمرات صحفيه سابقه قبل
حقيبه الخارجيه تعرف باردغان عام 2003
تشابهت الرؤى عوده تركيا لاحضان الشرق
وتعزيز قوتها الناعمه في دول اسيا الوسطى
والقوقع
اصبحت عمليات مكافحه التجسس التي تقوم بها
الوكاله الوكاله الاستخباراتيه التركيه
اكثر بروزا خلال رئاسه فيدان تم القبض على
خلايا تجسس تابعه لكل من اسرائيل وروسيا
وايران ولطالما كان منصب وزير الخارجيه في
تركيا بمثابه خطوه اخيره قبل الوصول لراس
السلطه سواء كرئيس او رئيس الوزراء
الامثله كثيره من عصمت اينينو ومسعود
ايلمز وصولا الى عبد الله غول واحمد داوود
اوغلو فهل كانت خطوه اردوغان لاخراج بدانه
من رسم السياسه الخارجيه في الظل الى
النور تمهيدا لاعلان خليفته
حكومه اردوغان ما زالت حديث الشارع التركي
فهي من اكثر حكومات التكنوقراط التي شكلها
الرئيس التركي لكن هناك اسماء لاقت
اهتماما خاصا طبعا في مقدمتهم هاكان فيدان
رجل الدوله القوي او رجل الظل رئيس
الاستخبارات السابق ووزير الخارجيه الحالي
شكل فيدان محور النفوذ التركي في اذربيجان
وليبيا وعده دول وتراس اجتماعات تطبيع
العلاقات مع بعض دول المنطقه لديه علاقات
جيده مع روسيا وايضا مع الغرب لذلك ينظر
اليه انه ميزان العلاقات التركيه ما بين
الشرق والغرب
الاقتصاد مجددا هو اولويه اردوغان الليره
التركيه شهدت قبل ايام تراجع عن قياسيا
مقابل الدولار بعد الانتخابات وهي التي
عمل المصرف المركزي على دعمها قبل
الانتخابات لكن بصمات الفريق الاقتصادي
الجديد يبدو انها ظهرت بسرعه وبعد تعيين
شمشك الذي يحظى بشعبيه لدى المستثمرين
العالميين ارتفعت اسعار سندات تركيا
المقومه بالدولار كما انخفضت تكلفه
الحمايه من التخلف عن سداد الديون التركيه
محمد شمشك هو اسم اخر لاق اهتماما لدى
الاتراك كيف لا وهو الذي يدير الملف
الاقتصادي من خلال وزاره الخزانه والماليه
وخفض التضخم من ابرز اولوياته يقال هنا ان
شمشك اراد فريقا اقتصاديا متناغما مع
افكاره لذلك برز اسم جوادي الماز النائبا
للرئيس وتعيين اردوغان لحفيظه جاي اركان
محافظا للبنك المركزي وهي اول امراه تتولى
هذا المنصب في تاريخ البلاد
[موسيقى]
في الازمه الليبيه تتبدل اطراف الصراع
كثيرا لكن شيئا وحيدا يظل ثابتا معاناه
الليبيين
ما نزاع القانوني باستمرار وكانواه الصراع
السياسي والعسكري ومن اجل ذلك جاء دور
لجنه سته زائد سته هي لجنه مشتركه تاسست
في مارس الماضي سته اعضاء من مجلس نواب
ومثلهم من مجلس الدوله والهدف هو اعداد
القوانين الانتخابيه وتجاوز الخلافات التي
كانت سببا في عدم عقد انتخابات ديسمبر
2021 هذه اللجنه وعلى مدى الاسبوعين
الماضيين دخلت في مفاوضات مكثفه في مدينه
بوزنيقه في المغرب وماذا عن النتيجه
رسميا تم التوافق على قانون الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في ديسمبر المقبل
لكن بلا توقيعا على الاتفاق بانتظار حضوري
رئيس البرلمان عقيل صالح ورئيس مجلس
الدوله خالد المشري
تم التوافق بين لجنتين لجنه سته زائد سته
من مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله على
قانون لانتخابات الرئاسه وانتخابات
البرلمان
وننتظر في الايام القادمه
[موسيقى]
حضور السيد رئيس مجلس النواب ورئيس مجلس
الدوله
التوقيع او
البث في
الاتفاق النهائي في
بخصوص هذا هذا القانون
[موسيقى]
تحدث ممثل مجلس النواب الليبي كما تابعنا
عن حضور رئيس المجلسين خلال الايام
المقبله لكن مصادر العربيه تفيد بان رئيس
البرلمان عقيل صالح غادر اصلا بوزنيقه
بسبب خلافات حول بعض بنود مشاريع القانون
القوانين ما هي الخلافات اذا هي ذاتها مثل
المره الماضيه الاختلاف بشان الشروط
الترشح للرئاسه وتحديدا السماح للعسكريين
والسياسيين من نظام القذافي بجانب مزدوجي
الجنسيه من الليبيين بالترشح للانتخابات
مجلس الدوله لا يريد ترشح شخصيات ليبيه
مثل قائد الجيش حليفه خليفه حفتر وسيف
الاسلام القذافي نجد معمر القذافي نفس ما
تريده حكومه البيبه والمليشيات غرب ليبيا
فيما يرغب مجلس النواب بمنح فرصه الترشح
لكل الليبيين دون اقصاء احد لكن حتى واذا
توافقت الاطراف الليبيه حول قانون
الانتخابات الاتفاق لن يكون ذا قيمه الا
بشرط
النص نص الاتفاق مهما كان كيبقى نص اذا لم
تواكبه اراده سياسيه حقيقيه
ليكون تكون هذا الاتفاقات عندها
الامكانيه باش تنزل على ارض الواقع
ان وقع الاتفاق قديم مرافقتي اداره اراده
سياسيه للحل في ليبيا كما تحدث بوريطه هل
بقيه الاعضاء اعضاء المجلسين يوافقون على
هذا الامر لا يبدو ذلك اللجنه تواجه
انتقادات كبيره 60 نائبا في البرلمان ما
حملوا رئاسه المجلس مسؤوليه التوقيعي او
الموافقه على مخرجات اللجنه دون الرجوع
الى البرلمان اما مجلس الدوله 54 من
اعضائه رفضوا مخرجات اللجنه شككوا في
شرعيتها ودعوا لرفض اي تسريبات بشان
القوانين الانتخابيه كما اعلنوا رفضهم
التعديل الدستوري الثالث عشر
[موسيقى]
العرض الذي طابع بعناه عن التعديل
الدستوري الثالث عشر ينقلنا الى سؤال اخر
ماذا ان لم يتوافق الطرفان على قانون
الانتخابات كما تحدثت المصادر سيتم اللجوء
للخطط البديله التي اعلن عنها المبعوث
الاممي لليبيا عبد الله بتيلي بتيلي اصلا
انتقد بشده هذا التعديل الدستوري الذي جاء
قبل
احاطته في مجلس الامن في فبراير الماضي
ووجه حديثه لمجلس النواب والدوله
سيختبر الوقت هذا الالتزام العلني الجديد
من مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى للدوله
وقادتهم سيكونون مسؤولين عن اقوالهم امام
ليبيا والمجتمع الدولي
المهله التي حددها بتيل من اجل الوصول
والتوصل لاتفاق تنتهي بحلول منتصف يونيو
وقتها سيتم تشكيل لجنه امميه رفيعه
المستوى لاعداد القاعده الدستوريه وقوانين
الانتخابات ستضم اعضاء من مجلس سيء النواب
والدوله بجانب اطراف اخرى فاعله غير ممثله
في المجلسين
من الاهميه بمكان للقاده الليبيين ان
يستجيبوا لهذا النداء الندائي شعبهم
وان
يتجاوز
المصالح الشخصيه
ويتجاوز ايضا المصالح
الفئويه وينظر الى مستقبل ليبيا
التطورات السياسيه في ليبيا ليست ببعيده
عن العسكريه وهنا لجنه اخرى ارقامها
مختلفه واطرافها ايضا لجنه 5 + 5 تشكلت
عام 2020 بموجب اتفاق في مؤتمر برلين خمسه
اعضاء عسكريين من المنطقه الغربيه وخمسه
عسكريين من الجيش الوطني الليبي في
المنطقه الشرقيه والهدف اعاده الامن
وتوحيد المؤسسه العسكريه التي انقسمت عام
منذ 2020 وحتى الان نجحت اللجنه في حل عدد
من الملفات ومنها التي كانت تغلقه
الميليشيات كما وضعت اللجنه خطه لترحيل
المرتزقه والمقاتلين الاجانب الا ان
الصراعات السياسيه حول هذا الامر عطلت
التنفيذ وتوقفت اعمال اللجنه قبل ان تعود
مره اخرى في يناير الماضي
[موسيقى]
ليست فقط اللجان في ليبيا متعدده الحكومات
كذلك هناك حكومتان الاولى حكومه حكومه
مكلفه من البرلمان برئاسه اسامه حماد كان
وزيرا للماليه قبل تكليفه بمهامة الحكومه
في مايو الماضي حيث صوت البرلمان على
ايقاف فتح بشاغه واحالته للتحقيق الحكومه
الثانيه هي حكومه الوحده الوطنيه برئاسه
عبد الحميد الدبيبه الذي رفض طوال العام
الماضي تسليم السلطه للحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان وطبعا وجود حكومتين ادى لتفاقم
الوضع العسكري دعونا نلقي نظره على اماكن
السيطره في ليبيا الحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان تفرض سيطرتها على شرق وجنوب
ليبيا حيث تمتد سيطرتها من اقصى الشرق في
الحدود الليبيه المصريه الى ما بعد المدخل
الغربي لسرت في الشمال بالاضافه الى اغلب
مناطق الجنوب وهي تعمل في اماكن سيطره
الجيش الوطنيه الليبي بقياده خليفه حفتر
اما طرابلس الواقعه في غرب ليبيا والقريبه
من الحدود مع تونس فهي تقع بالكامل تحت
سيطره القوات التابعه لحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه بقياده عبد الحميد الدبابه وهي
نقطه الصراع المشتعله حاليا في الساحل
الغربي الليبي هي مدينه الزاويه حيث اطلقت
حكومه الدبيبه عمليات بالمسيرات قالت انها
للقضاء على الخارجين عن القانون
تم دراستها تم دراسه مواقع
خطوط التهريب وخطوط التهريب البشره وتهريب
البنزينه او دخول
الكوكايين والهيروين والمخدرات بجميع
انواعها
وتم الحقيقه
عديده
بتحديد دقيق يجولي يجولي العمليه احنا
طبعا العمليات كمرحله اولى
عمليات جويه ونهب نقول لكم يا ليبيين او
نقول لكم في اللي يقول من دوله هدي ولا من
دوله هدي هذه الطيارات ملك للشعب الليبي
اللي انتم كلكم تملكوا هذه الطياره من
يوجهون هذه الطائرات المهمه والحديثه هم
الليبيين تم تدريبهم
وبينما يركز الغرب و واشنطن على الحرب في
اوكرانيا تبحث روسيا عن النقاط ضعفه في
بقيه العالم افريقيا منها وليبيا تحديدا
حيث يراها بوتين ارض الفرص وقام جلاتين
[موسيقى]
ورقه النفط هي ساحه لتصفيه الحسابات
السياسيه في ليبيا ومطمعا لدول الغربيه في
فبراير 2022 كانت ليبيا تخسر يوميا 60
مليون دولار بسبب الخلاف بين الدبابه
وبشاغه كان لابد من ايجاد حلول ووجدت
ليبيا الحل في تقنيه الحقول النفطيه
الذكيه وهي هذه التقنيه ستتيح التحكم في
عمليه الانتاج عن بعد عبر غرفه تحكم مجهزه
بالكامل تسمح بالوصول الى البيانات
التشغيليه الحيه ومراقبه النتائج الالات
الصناعيه في الموقع ستعمل مع البرامج
واجهزه الاستشعار لتوفير البيانات وتحديد
المشاكل والاعطال والتي كانت تقتضي في
السابق زيارات ميدانيه
لناخذ مثالا هناك خزانات بها زيوت ثقيله
صعبه الاستخراج لذا لجات بعض الشركات
لتطوير تقنيات لتعزيز الانتاج مثل اداه
البيانات والتي تجعل وتجمع مليون
معلومه كل دقيقتين من عشره الاف بئر وبنيه
تحتيه محيطه هذه الاداه توفر مؤشرات
الرئيسيه عن الابار وحاله الخزان ترسلها
لغرف التحكم وبالتالي القرار افضل والكلفه
اقل حتى الوقت المستغرق ما كان يحدث في
يومين يتم الان في الساعه او ساعتين هذه
التقنيه ستساعد ايضا في استكشاف ابار
نفطيه جديده خلال مده قصيره عبر تقديم
بيانات عن الغاز والنفط الى غرفه التحكم
لتحديد جوده النفط
[موسيقى]
ومن القاهره ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي
والباحث في الشان الليبيه عبد الستار
احتيتا اهلا بك بعدما يقال عن فشل اللجنه
سته زائد سته ما هو البديل الان في ليبيا
اعتقد ان السيد عبد الله بتيلي سوف يبدا
في اجراءات لتشكيل لجنه ليبيه جديده
تجب اللجنتين التي ان شكلهما مجلس النواب
ومجلس الدوله او لجنه 6 + 6 لكن باتيلي
يبدو مرن يعني يمكن ان يستعين باطراف من
مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله ويمكن ان يبني
على ما وصلت اليه
مخرجات لجنه سته زائد سته باعتبار انها
يعني حققت هنا السؤال سيد حتاته يعني هل
تعتقد ان البعثه الامميه هذه اللجنه
ستعتمد على مخرجات سته زائد سته من ضم
يعني من مجلس النواب وايضا مجلس الدوله
وشخصيات مدنيه وحزبيه ام انها تستبعد
النواب ومجلس الدوله وتعتمد على شخصيات
مدنيه
اعتقد ان السيد بديل على تواصل مع مجلس
النواب ومجلس الدوله وبالتالي اللجنه انا
اعتقد انها ستكون او ستضم اعضاء من مجلس
النواب ومجلس الدوله بالاضافه الى قيادات
من نشطاء ومن مراه ومن شباب وحتى من
القيادات الامنيه المحسوبه على
الميليشيات والجماعات المسلحه في شمال غرب
ليبيا من اجل انجاز الانتخابات السيد عبد
الله البتيلي يريد انجاز الانتخابات
وانجاز الانتخابات الانتخابات يحتاج الى
الحديث مع الجميع والى تلافي الاخطاء التي
وقعت فيها لجنه سته زائد سته او عدم
التوافق الذي
تمحور حول بعض البنود الصغيره والمهمه في
الحقيقه في لجنه 6 + 6 اعتقد ان السيد
باتيلي يتواصل مع مجلس النواب وهو اعتقد
انه استمع خلال الساعات الماضيه الى احد
القيادات في مجلس النواب حول انه يعني يتم
العوده مره اخرى الى اللج الاساسيه
للدستور وعشان منظر القبيل
ولهذا انا اقول ان الصيد بتيلي يمكن ان
يعتمد على مخرجات سته سته بالاضافه الى
رؤيته في ضم مجموعات اخرى من النشاطين في
الدوله الليبيه بمن فيهم من الامراء الحرب
في شمال الغرب ليبيا نعم نعم هناك اطراف
اقليميه ودوليه تريد اجراء الانتخابات
البرلمانيه اولا وابقاء الحل هكذا يعني
الحال هكذا لمده سنه او اكثر على الوضع
الحالي ولكن مع اجراء انتخابات برلمانيه
[موسيقى]
الاطراف الليبيه والاطراف الاقليميه
والدوليه
انه يسير في مصاري يؤدي الى الانتخابات
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره الكاتب
الصحفي والباحث في الشان الليبي عبد
الستار
الاول منذ 130 عاما الذي يدلي بشهادته في
الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد منذ القرن التاسع عشر اي
اكثر من 130 سنه لم يدلي اي فردا من
العائله الملكيه البريطانيه بشهاده امام
المحكمه اخر من فعل ذلك كان ادويد السابع
لكن الطريق تغير على يد الامير هاري
والسبب مقاضاته لمجموعه مرر الصحفيه
الامير هاري يتهم المجموعه بانها اخترقت
هاتفه واستخدمت وسائل اخرى غير قانونيه
لجمع معلومات عن حياته بين عامي 1996 و
2019 بعض المحررين الصحفيين تلطخت ايديهم
بالدماء ربما هو موت من غير قصد كانت هذه
بعض كلمات هاري امام المحكمه يقصد هاري
طبعا ما نشرته الصحافه عن والدته الاميره
ديانا امر لا يريد هاري ان يتكرر مع
اطفاله
لقد كانت والدتي وحيده تحاول ان ترعى
طفليها مع كل هذه المضايقات الاعلاميه
الشديده كانت تطارد معظم حياتها عندما
كانت مع والدي وبتل الامر اسوا عندما تم
الطلاق لذلك فانا افعل كل ما في وسعي
للتاكد من عدم حدوث ذلك لعائلتي وساستمر
في ذلك لانه بالتاكيد لا يبدو ان الصحافه
البريطانيه قد غيرت طرقها
هذه ليس وحده نحن 100 من المشاهير يقادون
المجموعه الصحفيه التي اعتدرت بالفعل
لهاري واكدت انه يحق له الحصول على
تعويضنا مناسب ورغم الاعتذار تصر الشركه
المالكه لمجموعه مرار الصحفيه انه لا لو
مع المديرين التنفيذيين لان هذا النشاط
غير القانوني اخفي بشكل مقصود من قبل
الصحفيين لكن ما يمكن ان يضحك هذه الفرضيه
ان احد الادعاءات الرئيسيه في القضيه هو
ان مقدم البرامج التلفزيونيه كيرلس مورجان
والذي تراس تحرير المرر منذ عام 1995 وحتى
2004 كان على علم بهذا النشاط غير
القانوني مورجن من ناحيته نفى مرارا
التورط في الاختراقات غير القانونيه فهل
يمكن ان يقدم اعتذاره نهائي
لن اتلقى محاضراتنا عن انتهاك الخصوصيه من
الامير هاري هو شخص قضى اخر ثلاث سنوات
بسخريه وبلا رحمه في انتهاك خصوصيه
العائله المالكه من اجل لعبه تجاريه واسعه
وعبر مجموعه من الاكاذيب التي قالها لذلك
انا اقترح عليه ان يخرج من المحكمه وان
يعتبر لعائلته عن انتهاكه المشير للخصوصي
هي اللحظه التي انتظرها الامير هاري منذ
سنوات محاسبه الاعلام على ما يقول انها
معاناه تسبب بها ليس بحقه فقط وانما بحق
والدته الراحل الامير ديانا وبحق مقربين
منه ايضا محاكمه هذا الاسبوع ضد مجموعه
صحف مر هي واحده من بين ثلاث محاكمات
يخضها هذه ضد صحافه التاب يستند في
الدعاءته الى مقالات اخباريه يقول انه
يريد معرفه كيفيه جمع معلوماتها ويتهم
الصحف باستخدام طرق غير قانونيه في
الاصوليه عليها
33 مقاله سئل عنها بادق التفاصيل في جلستك
محاكمه استمرت اكثر من 8 ساعات خلال يومين
محامي الدفاع اندروغرين سال هاري اكثر من
مره هل مزاعمه تستند الى تكهنات ام انها
تستند الى ادله متوفره ما يعني ان توفر
الادله هو الذي سيحسم القضيه لصالح احد
الطرفين هذه بدا متوترا في البدايه لكنه
اصبح اكثر هدوءا مع مرور الوقت واكثر جراه
في ردوده في اليوم الثاني قد يفوز هاري
بالراي العام لكن سيحتاج اكثر من مشاعر
التعاطف لاقناع القاضي باساءه الصحافه له
[موسيقى]
اسمه ايلون ماسك لا يختفي من الاخبار او
بالاحرى من التهم الاسبوع الماضي تحدثنا
عن اتهامات المعلومات المضلله وانسحاب
تويتر من ميثاق مكافحتها الخاص باوروبا
هذا الاسبوع يواجه ماسك وتويتر تطبيقا اخر
والسبب هذه المره الخصوصيه بعد عمليات
تسريح واستقالات واسعه النطاق في المنصه
منذ استحواذ ماسك على المنصه وان كان
الملياردير الامريكي يرى الامر منطقيا
كيف تدير الشركه بعشرين بالمئه فقط من
الموظفين
لست بحاجه الى كل هذا العدد الكبير من اجل
تشغيل تويتر 80% هذا كثير
نعم اذا كنت تحاول اداره هذا النوع من
المنظمه النشطه والكبيره فانت لا تهتم
كثيرا بالرقابه وبالتالي يمكنك التخلي عن
الكثير من الناس كما اتضح
تويتر لا يمتثل لمعايير الخصوصيه تويتر
انتهك قوانين حمايه المستهلك ماسك لا
يبالي وهو ليس اكبر من القانون كان هذا
ملخص رساله اربعه اعضاء ديموقراطيين في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي ووجهت الى ماسك
ولندا يا كارينو المديره التنفيذيه
الجديده لتويتر الرساله تضمنت ايضا
تساؤلات للمنصه هل تحتفظ ابي برنامج شامل
للامن السيبراني لحمايه البيانات الاجرى
التقييما الخصوصيه والامان لخدمه تويتر
بلو قبل طرحها
منحها النواب لموسكو للمنصه حق الرد لكن
وفق مهله تنتهي في الثامن عشر من يونيو لم
يرد تويتر حتى الان لكن ماسك تحدث عن
الامر سابقا ورد على الاتهام
افقدتني صوابي درجه الفعاليه التي كانت
تتمتع بها الوكالات الحكوميه المختلفه
للوصول الكامل الى كل ما كان يحدث على
تويتر لم اكن على علم بذلك والرسائل
الخاصه ايضا
نعم
ورغم حديثي ماسك واتهامه الوكالات
الحكوميه الامريكيه باختراق الخصوصيه لكن
رساله النواب استشهدت في اتهامها ماسك
بامر اخر حدث قبل ايام زاد قلقهم استقاله
ثاني استقاله ثاني رئيسه لقسم الثقه
والسلامه تحت قياده ماسك
[موسيقى]
القلق ليس مقتصرا على النواب الاربعه لجنه
لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه تحقق منذ 2011 مع
تويتر لكن كثفت هذه التحقيقات بعد استحواذ
ماسك اللجنه طلبت من المنصه توضيحات حول
ما اذا كانت تمتلك الموارد اللازمه او
الفريق الكافي لامتثال لاتفاقيه الخصوصيه
وبحسب تصريحات احد المطلعين على التفاصيل
لوكاله رويترز وان ثبتت انتهاكات المنصه
قد تواجه غرامات بمليارات الدولارات من
لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه لكن ايلون ماسك
ما يخاف من اللجنه فهو يضع الصواريخ في
الفضاء هكذا يرى الامر اليكسبيرو محامي
ماسك
التحقيق الذي تجريه لجنه التجاره
الفيدراليه مع ماسكي يواجهه انتقادات
تحديدا من الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
واللجنه القضائيه التي يتراسها الجمهوري
جيم جوردن
ظهر هذا الامر جليا في مارس الماضي جلسه
الاستماع كانت صاخبه في مبنى الكابتن
حضرتها رئيسه اللجنه لنخان اللجنه
القضائيه بحثت مزاعم بان لجنه التجاره
الفيدراليه اساءت استخدام سلطتها النتيجه
كانت تقريرا من ثماني عشره صفحه اتهم فيها
الجمهوريون اتهم فيها الجمهوريون لجنه
التجاره بتنظيم حمله لمهاجمه تويتر
التقرير اشار الى ان هذا التحقيق جاء
نتيجه لضغط حزبي والهدف استهداف تويتر
واسكاتو ماسك التقرير رفضه المتحدث باسم
لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه
التحقيقات مباشره وليست سياسيه
[موسيقى]
اشد والجذب والملاحقات لماسك ليست الوحيده
الملياردير الامريكيه محاصر بالتهم هذه
المره بشان العملات الرقميه
مجموعه من المستثمرين اقترحوا رفع دعوه
جمعيه ضد ماسك بتهمه التلاعب بهذه
العمليات ورفع سعرها عمدا لاكثر من سته
وثلاثين الفا في المئه على مدار عامين ثم
تركها تنهار وما كلفهم مليارات الدولارات
استخدم ماسك في ذلك عده وسائل منشورات
تويتر منها
[موسيقى]
رغم اهميه تطبيق واتساب للتواصل الا انه
اصبح في الاعوام الاخيره مصدرا رئيسيا لبث
القلق والاكتئاب من الان وحتى المقبله انا
حنين الشولي وهذه الساعه 60
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات